viral meningitis is an infection
occurring mostly in children under age
five it happens when certain viruses
invade the meninges which are the
tissues that cover and protect the brain
and spinal cord the meninges are
arranged in three layers the layer that
actually touches the brain and spinal
cord is called the Pia mater
the spider web-like middle layer is
called the arachnoid mater the outermost
and toughest layer is called the dura
mater
cerebrospinal fluid which also protects
the brain and spinal cord flows between
the meninges and over the surface of the
brain
the most common cause of viral
meningitis is a type of virus called
enterovirus
other viruses that can cause meningitis
include the mumps virus
the measles virus
herpes viruses
and a variety of viruses spread by blood
feeding insects such as mosquitoes and
ticks
viruses that cause meningitis may be
spread through the bite of an infected
insect
however the two most common ways the
viruses spread are through fecal
contamination which can happen when
hands are not washed after using the
toilet or changing a diaper and through
contact with the body fluids from an
infected person such as through sneezing
or coughing once inside the body the
viruses make copies of themselves
and enter the bloodstream
viruses travel through the bloodstream
to the brain where they cross the border
between the bloodstream and the brain
into the cerebrospinal fluid the viruses
spread throughout the cerebrospinal
fluid and infect the cells of the
meninges the meninges become inflamed as
the immune system begins to fight off
the infection
symptoms of viral meningitis in infants
and young children include fever
irritability
loss of appetite
trouble waking up
symptoms in older children and adults
include fever
headache
stiff neck
sensitivity to light
sleepiness
trouble waking up
nausea
vomiting
and loss of appetite
the symptoms of viral meningitis are
similar to those of bacterial meningitis
but are usually less severe
doctors may recommend acetaminophen or
other non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs for fever and headache for
meningitis caused by a type of herpes
virus doctors may prescribe an antiviral
medication such as acyclovir
there is no treatment for most viruses
that cause meningitis though most people
recover on their own within two weeks